mesdames et messieurs mes chers amis je
voudrais remercier tous ceux qui ont
conduit ce travail autour de notre
secrétaire général eric woerth au
tournoi qui fait honneur à notre famille
politique ça fait plaisir de voir des
gens qui ont du courage qu'ils assument
leurs convictions je remercie tous les
parlementaires qui sont ici un cher
christian jean bernard pouy chers amis
chers daniel je me prend dans un pack
est terrible parce que dans ces bastia
vannes
voilà yannick moreau c'est un sujet très
important qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
d'abord chez hervé pour nous les
républicains
les choses sont claires le progrès la
recherche la connaissance l'innovation
ne sont pas un problème c'est la
solution
le choix des républicains
c'est patent cher jean-claude n'est sûr
j'y reviendrai le nucléaire ou telle ou
telle technique le choix fondamental des
républicains c'est notre croyance dans
le progrès dans l'innovation dans la
recherche et notre confiance dans les
chercheurs disons les choses comme elles
sont il y à un climat quasiment
moyenâgeux de défiance à l'endroit des
chercheurs des scientifiques du progrès
de la recherche et de l'innovation
jamais la france n'a eu autant besoin de
recherche de progrès d'innovation et
jamais on n'a autant entendu de sottises
sur la décroissance sur les risques que
faisait peser la recherche et sur le
progrès un peu comme si on était revenu
aux années 70 le dénommé six commandes
shell et le club
rome diffuser cette idée absurde que
l'idéal c'était la croissance zéro
fermant ainsi la porte du progrès au nez
à la barbe de tous les pays qui ne
l'avait pas à l'époque il y avait peu de
chômage mais il y avait énormément de
pauvreté partout dans le monde et c'est
parce que nous croyons dans le progrès
que nous avons décidé de renoncer au
principe de précaution qui est devenu un
principe d'inaction dans un contexte de
sur interprétations
pardon c'est pas pour faire des mon père
louis parce que l'idée de la précaution
était une bonne idée
je ne peux en faire le procès à personne
mais le principe de précaution a été
surinterprétée et c'est devenu un
principe d'inaction c'est pas acceptable
c'est pas tolérable et la première
mesure concrète que nous proposons tour
de mode et d'eric woerth c'est de
transformer le principe de précaution en
principe de responsabilité la différence
c'est très simple au nom de la
précaution vous abstenu de faire au nom
de la responsabilité vous faites et vous
en assumer les conséquences
c'est exactement le choix politiques
majeurs qui rassemble tous les
républicains
j'ajoute et je ne comprends même pas
qu'on puisse contester cela sans
recherche et sans innovation qui
développera la nouvelle génération de
véhicules électriques hybrides t
l'étranger sans chercher sans innovation
qui relèvera le défi indispensable du
changement climatique dans le domaine du
stockage de l'énergie de la
séquestration de carbone ou
l'intégration de la production d'énergie
délocaliser dans les réseaux locaux qui
commet le formateur sans recherche et en
innovation
est-ce qu'on va être le seul pays au
monde qui par principe ou par précaution
il n'y aura les ressources potentielles
de nos sous
qu'on arrête la recherche y a plus un
seul permis de recherche
on peut être parfaitement contre la
fracturation hydraulique et nous sommes
content mais justement la recherche
permet de trouver d'autres techniques
qui permettra de voir si dans nos sous
sols
il n'y a pas un jour où un autre pour
nos enfants pour nos petits enfants pour
nous mêmes des ressources énergétiques
dont on aurait besoin si on arrête la
recherche
comment va le trouver sans recherche et
en innovation qui va développer les
biocarburants de deuxième génération
produit à partir des déchets de
l'industrie agroalimentaire des résidus
agricoles des ordures ménagères des
rejets végétaux qui d autre et pas nous
face au changement climatique
les océans les forêts l'agriculture
constituent des opportunités
fantastiques de puits à carbone
nous voulons lancer un grand programme
national de développement des puits de
carbone qui sont que sont la biomasse
forestière sur pied et le bois d'oeuvre
sans recherche qui le fera nous croyons
donc donc progrès une transformant le
principe de précaution en principe de
responsabilité c'est une troisième idée
que nous voulons avancer
nous voulons sortir de cette écologie
punitive qui dénonce qui donne des
leçons qui pointe du doigt des
professionnels une écologie punitive qui
est une écologie de posture et
d'idéologie al'inverse ce que nous
voulons faire une écologie de
partenariats chez christian ce que tu
mets en oeuvre dans la région et nous
voulons adresser à l'ensemble des
acteurs de l'environnement un message
très fort nous voulons dire aux
agriculteurs aux marins pêcheurs aux
chasseurs qu'ils sont les premiers
acteurs de la préservation de
l'environnement et de la protection de
la biodiversité pour nous agriculteurs
chasseurs pêcheurs ne sont pas des
adversaires
ce sont des partenaires avec lesquels
nous voulons travailler pour préserver
la biodiversité et l'environnement
j'aimerais qu'on m'explique quel est
l'intérêt des chasseurs des pêcheurs et
des agriculteurs à la destruction de la
terre des mères
des forêts s'efface dire cela c'est
s'opposer espèces de 2 boboïsation
permanente
on a quand même entendu a misé
agriculture dire que l'avenir de
l'agriculture
c'était la vente à la ferme on imagine
une robe en dentelle ou tino papillon on
va acheter ses yeux à la ferme c'est la
vision de l'agriculture
aujourd'hui les circuits courts jeu rien
contre jose après sympathique
on peut même prendre une photo et la
mettre dans un cadre mais enfin qui peut
penser que c'est la réponse aux défis
économiques fantastiques de la première
agriculture d'europe et je veux que le
message sur les censeurs soit bien
entendu j'étais hier en picardie cher
bernard baudin est ce que j'ai dit aux
chasseurs je le confirme ici
vous n'êtes pas des adversaires vous
êtes des partenaires je le dis aux
pêcheurs je le dis aux marins pêcheurs
jeunes agriculteurs nous voulons
travailler avec vous dans un cadre
contractuel
alors doucement dit aussi autre chose et
c'est un quatrième engagement pour nous
nous voulons mettre un terme définitif à
la sueur transposition des normes
européennes plus aucune norme au dessus
de la moyenne européenne en france et
nous voulons autre chose
l'énorme adam qui seront adoptées
préalablement doit faire l'objet d'une
consultation et d'une expertise
scientifique encore s'il ya une espèce
en voie de disparition
nous serons nous les républicains les
premiers à demander la préservation de
cette espèce l'arrêt de la chasse
l'arrêt de la pêche mais pour cela il
faut avant toute norme une concertation
et une analyse scientifique
le problème des oies comment voulez vous
que dans la bêtise
et puissent comprendre qu'on limite la
chasse au gibier d'eau et notamment des
joies alors que la même année en
hollande qui sur le chemin pour la
migration
il décide de d'exterminer 150me loi
parce que c'est une espèce en voie de
prolifération
je suis désolé je dois pas être très
compétent mais ça m'étonnerait qu'on
puisse dire en france loi est en voie
d'extinction et en le holland loi est en
voie d'expansion
il faut se mettre d'accord choisir et à
partir de ce moment là si c'est une
expansion autorisant la chasse
si l'espèce est en voie d'extinction
interdisant la chasse mais ça doit pas
être trop compliqué alors que nous
sommes en europe que l'europe s'occupe
de ça plutôt que la courbe des
concombres ou le nom de barrow d'échelle
pour un apprenti de moins de 16 ans il
me semble que là il ya vraiment matière
à voir une réglementation européenne
puisque comme vous le savez les oiseaux
migrateurs ne dépose pas leur permis de
chasse et de vol avant de franchir des
frontières
donc vous l'avez compris chasseurs
partenariat concertation avant toute
norme expertise scientifique nous
n'avons pas peur de l' expertise
scientifique
bien au contraire j'ajoute un dernier
élément plus aucune norme qui ne fasse
l'objet d'une évaluation tous les cinq
ans car le problème n'est pas tant la
norme
après tout nous considérons qu'il faut
des règles parce que dans une économie
fut élu est qu une marche et si a plus
de règle c'est la loi de la jungle
le problème c'est que c'est une bataille
phénoménal pour la règle et après tout
le monde s'en moque
est on sûr écrit sur interprète
surajoute des normes toutes les normes
devraient faire l'objet d'une évaluation
tous les cinq ans celles qui sont utiles
on les garde
celles qui ne sont pas utiles on les
change
le changement climatique je voudrais
dire avant en ouverture de ce thème une
question posée une question qui est à
mes yeux absolument centrale la terre a
une ancienneté 4 milliards 500 millions
d'années des changements climatiques la
terre en a connu d'immenses et encore
pas si longtemps il yad'autres millions
d'années une période de glaciation
extraordinaire qui faisait qu'on allait
à pied pas moi sur mes qu'on allait à
pied
grosso modo de l'alaska de ce qui est
aujourd'hui l'alaska jusqu'à l'école
puisque et d'ailleurs par parenthèse à
l'époque c'est une bonne amie et moi ses
proches du site je remercie de cette
confiance j'ai vu qu'il y avait un
moment vous croyez ça a permis la
colonisation de la planète par les êtres
humains donc des changements climatiques
le monde
la planète on a connu quantité ça veut
pas dire qu'il ne faut pas s'en occuper
comme comprennent bien dans l'inconnu
quantité il ya un phénomène que nous
n'avons jamais connu
jamais c'est la pression démographique
planétaire qui va nous amener
donnez-vous bien à passer de 7 milliards
d'habitants à 11 milliards et demi en
2100 demain matin aux milliards et demi
personne n'a jamais vécu ça sur la
planète
il y aura à ce moment-là plus
d'habitants sur la planète qu'il y en a
à l'heure actuelle
depuis les premiers hominidés il ya
trois millions d'années sont arrivés
excusez moi ça me paraît un défi un peu
plus considérables que le seul défi du
réchauffement climatique je ne conteste
nullement qu'on s'occupe de cela
mais alors qu'on a mis une coop 21 puis
une coque 22 au maroc sur les
changements climatiques
les républicains demandent une
conférence mondiale annuelle sur la
démographie mondiale sur la nécessité
d'un planning familial
de la définition d'une stratégie
démographique sur la planète
nous demandons également la création
d'une institution internationale qui
porterait sur et eric l'organisation de
cette conférence est qui mesurerait les
évolutions démographiques continent par
continent
quand même insensé que ne se préoccupe
pas d'une chose dans 30 ans le premier
pays en démographie du monde sera l'inde
le deuxième sera la chine le troisième
sera le nigeria le nigeria aura dans 30
en plus d'habitants à lui tout seul que
les états unis d'amérique
peut-être l'équipe c'est pas un opinion
ce pas un avis c'est une certitude
on peut par dont une absolue certitude
donc on peut continuer longtemps
mais si on se désintéresse du problème
démographique mondiale cela signifie
qu'on ne s'attaque pas aux causes de la
pollution car la première cause de la
pollution
pourquoi il ya des villes pourquoi il ya
une ex sur l'exploitation des recettes
énergétiques hérite de la planète
pourquoi il ya tous les problèmes des
missions que l'on connaît parce que y'a
un problème démographique majeur dont on
ne s'occupe pas j'ai eu l'occasion avec
un certain nombre d'entre vous notamment
eric woerth d'aller m'exprimer devant
les étudiants ivoiriens à l'université
de tripoli
je leur ai dit que la croissance de
l'afrique était une formidable nouvelle
mais si la politique de natalité reste
est entre six et huit enfants par
famille en moyenne selon les pays
personne pas même les africains ne
pourrait imaginer une croissance qui
permettra d'éviter les famine le chômage
et les problèmes migratoires que nous
connaissons c'est une proposition donc
des républicains une conférence
nationale sur la démographie est une
institution je ne dis pas qu'il faut une
même politique sur tous les continents
c'est pas du tout
je dis simplement c'est quelque chose à
mes yeux de fondamental les républicains
nous demandons également l'interdiction
internationale de l'exploitation des
ressources minières pétrolières gas gas
year en arctique
alors du coup le réchauffement
climatique fait qu'à l'horizon 2020 on
va pouvoir utiliser la voie arctique
pour le passage des bateaux
il me semble qu'il serait de toute
urgence d'indiquer que les bateaux qui
passerait par cette voie qui va être
ouverte
ils sont les choses comme elles sont ce
serait des bateaux à double coque avec
des mesures de protection particulières
et que par ailleurs on peut également
décider que certaines matières ne
pourront pas être transporté car il ya
une différence entre l'article d autres
zones de la planète
c'est un dégazage dans le pacifique dans
l'océan indien atlantique s'est mangé
par toutes les bactéries assez
rapidement en articles compte tenu du
froid les conséquences écologiques d'un
désastre seraient bien pires
compte tenu du fait que la vie et
notamment la vie bactériologique y est
moins nombreuse l'énergie nucléaire j'ai
eu l'occasion de dire un mot de cela
dans un journal dimanche dernier et je
voudrais dire combien j'ai été heureux
d'entendre hervé mariton et jean paul
benoît d'abord les républicains
demandent une chose qu'on arrête de
faire de la filière nucléaire un enjeu
de la politique politicienne
c'est un scandale mesdames et messieurs
mes chers amis si le général de gaulle
georges pompidou valéry giscard
d'estaing françois mitterrand jacques
chirac et moi même c'est président la
république
nous avons constamment fait en matière
nucléaire les mêmes joies
parce que le nucléaire n'appartient pas
à la droite le nucléaire n'appartient
pas à la gauche le nucléaire appartient
à la france c'est un de ses atouts
majeurs
c'est des générations et des générations
de chercheurs
remarquable qui ont donné cet atout
france on n'a pas le droit de s'en
servir comme d'un enjeu politicien
monsieur hollande est le premier
président de la république un rompre le
consensus national sur le nucléaire
il portera une lourde responsabilité de
ce dont nous disposons pardon
jean-claude nous connaissez ça bien
mieux que moi nous disposons du deuxième
parc nucléaire mondial derrière les
etats unis qui génère plus de 75% de la
production d'électricité et odf et est
de loin le premier exploitant nucléaire
mondial
mais qu'est ce qu'on veut de la france
qu'on soit plus dépendant de nos amis
arabes alors que tous ceux qui me disent
il faut pas de relation et tirant faux
pas de relations avec l'arabie saoudite
parfait on arrête avec le nucléaire
on va le remplacer par quoi par une
dépendance accrue vis-à-vis ti j'ajoute
que je ne comprends pas cet acharnement
à scier la branche industrielle sur
laquelle nous sommes assis en espérant
qu'une autre pousse immédiatement jean
claude et revient dit des choses ne sont
qu elle j'ai pas besoin de revenir c'est
parfaitement exact mais qu'est ce qu'on
reproche à la filière nucléaire
française que vous les français vous
payer l'électricité 80 % moins cher que
les allemands non devrait les remercier
on devrait remercier la filière 80 %
moins chers que ceux qui veulent fermer
les centrales d aux français que demain
la facture augmentera de 80% c'est
intéressant et on verra ce que diront
les français
et par ailleurs ont produit cette fois
moins de co2 qu'est ce qu'on reproche à
cette filière d'avoir rendu la france
compétitive
j'ajoute que ce serait assez paradoxal
de voir la france a abandonné le
nucléaire au moment les anglais le
choisit c'était dire que les anglais
font confiance à notre technologie et
nous ne ferions pas confiance à six
décennies de recherche d'ingénieurs qui
ont chacun apporté depuis pierre et
marie curie leur formidable compétences
au service de la france
j'ajoute si un réacteur nucléaire est
dangereux pourquoi fermer fessenheim et
les yeux ouverts
les 53 autres oui je sais c'est simple
ce que je dis mais enfin cher louis je
comprends ce que je dis soit c'est
dangereux dans ce cas là il faut tout
serait fermée soit ça l'est pas il se
trouve que le rapport de l'autorité
indépendante de sûreté nucléaire sur mon
embauche était président de la
république je les commande et nous avons
pour fessenheim a permis d'exploiter de
dix ans ça veut pas dire que dans 10 ans
fermé c'est à dire que fessenheim une
autorité indépendante dit pendant dix
ans vous pouvez le continuer qu'est-ce
qu'on a peur de quoi
dans une amie sur le rhin franchement on
est un peu étonné de tout cela donc ré
sonne elle ne fermera pas et j'irai le
dire aux ouvriers de fessenheim
chers amis sur 20 ans sur 20 ans la
centrale de fessenheim rapportera fdf 7
milliards d'euros
alors j'ai entendu ta remarque un suaire
veille sur 7 milliards d'euros alors
voilà qu'on a assez d'argent pour
supprimer cette possibilité de recettes
cet après midi autour de derrick une
réunion point donné des arbitrages sur
la question de la défense rien de
fessenheim sur 20 ans ces 7 milliards
d'euros il faut fermer celles qu'on va
payer entre 3 et 4 milliards pour
indemniser les propriétaires et on va
naturellement se priver de la recette
c'est 11 milliards tout ça pour avoir le
soutien
de gens qui sont debout la nuit donc
couché le jour à moins qu'il n'ait pas
besoin de sommeil je dois reconnaître
que moi je suis couché la nuit debout le
jour 9 avance je sais c'est original
cette origine donc pas question de
fermer l'objectif à 50% en 2020 ils ont
tous les deux dit mais c'est absolument
impossible mais permettez moi d'avancer
une idée voilà un gouvernement qui se
fait fort de lutter contre les plans
sociaux et qui est en train d'organiser
le plus formidable plan social que notre
pays n'ait jamais connue avec la
fermeture de 50 % du parc nucléaire
français
voilà ce que fait le gouvernement dans
ce cas naturellement si on fermait
centrales nucléaires c'est un plan
social que inimaginable car
naturellement il faut que je dis il ya
des gens dans les centrales c'est
automatique
donc ce gouvernement dont la posture et
de dénoncer le moindre plan social d'une
entreprise qui a son carnet de commandes
en berne va donc s'attaquer à edf fixé
comme objectif qu à 2025 en coupe 50 %
de leur production en même temps puisque
ma main droite doit ignorer ce que fait
ma main gauche
on demande à edf de récupérer areva dans
une situation lamentable
donc on comme 50% de ce que fait edf on
demande à derb de payer pour reprendre
areva naturellement qu'est ce qu'on va
faire on va demander aux allemands de
bien alimenter leurs usines à charbon
pour nous donner l'électricité que nous
n'aurons pas c'est d'une logique
parfaite et de surcroît comme paquet
cadeau on organise le plus gigantesque
plan social dans la flûte filière
nucléaire française sous les yeux ébahis
du monde entier qui se demande si on
réfléchit à la tête de l'état de ce côté
là on a une réponse assez définitive
alors jean claude et non oui il faut
travailler les réacteurs nucléaires de
la 4ème génération astrid et là encore
je ne comprends pas me dire oui mais p r
la troisième génération de sites mais si
on arrête la recherche
on va donc pas investir dans la
quatrième génération
et quelle est la caractéristique de la
c'est qu'elle sera plus sécure que la
troisième comme la troisième est plus
sécure que la seconde est comme la
seconde est plus sécure que la première
donc ceux qui veulent arrêter la
recherche sur le nucléaire sont ceux qui
ne se préoccupent pas de la sûreté
nucléaire car naturellement dans la
recherche sur la quatrième génération
il ya toute la question de la protection
et de l'exigence de sécurité qui est
fort heureusement aujourd'hui bien
supérieures à ce qu'elles étaient il ya
50 ans je souhaite d'ailleurs que edf
réfléchissent à ses gammes de centrale
puisque hop et r on verra ce que ça
donne ensuite sinoussi sur le chantier
que j'ai vu il ya deux équipes qui
travaillent 12 ha bon donc c'est pas
tout à fait les mêmes règles en la
matière il nous appartient pas de porter
de deux jugements mais je souhaite qu
edf élargisse sa gamme pour avoir des
centrales que nous puissions exporté
dans des pays de 5 à 10 millions
d'habitants et chacun comprend bien que
quand vous avez 10 millions d'habitants
vous n'avez pas besoin d'un fantastique
réacteurs comme hop et r et encore une
fois je veux rendre hommage à la filière
qui a fait un travail absolument
remarquable
un dernier mot pour démolir une idée
fausse
mais qui a dit qu' à vue qui peut penser
que c'est le nucléaire qui empêche les
énergies les énergies renouvelables de
se développer
une erreur monumentale il ya deux choses
qui limite le développement des
renouvelables
c'est d'abord le coût pour le
consommateur et pour les finances
publiques via le contribution au service
public de l'électricité
et deuxièmement l'acceptabilité local
des projets parce que tout le monde n'a
pas envie d'avoir une hygiène le sol et
jeu au dessus de sa tête
aucun projet renouvelables aucun aucun
n'a jamais été empêché parce qu'il y
avait trop de nucléaire on pense je sais
pas où on a été chercher une affaire
comme ça ça n'existe pas alors il faut
dire la vérité des chiffres
nous dépensons chaque année 5 milliards
d'euros par an pour subventionner les
énergies renouvelables moi je veux
mettre les pieds dans le plat
ce montant va monter à 7 milliards en
2020 alors c'est moins que les allemands
qui sont à 20 milliards ça a été répétée
mais il est nécessaire de s'interroger
sur la pertinence d'une telle politique
dont je dis qu'elle n'a permis
l'émergence en france
doc une filière industrielle ou alors
qu'on me dise laquelle et qui a fait
grimper la facture des français à
travers la csp quand même écouter on
doit poser les questions telles que se
posent énergies renouvelables ou là je
suis pour mais la stratégie
d'aujourd'hui c'est quand même ça va
monter à 7 milliards par an que vous
l'avez évoqué tous les deux est ce qu'on
continue comme ça y'a pas de filière en
france
alors je pose la question parce que pour
moi l'objectif de développer les
énergies renouvelables ne peut se
réaliser au détriment du portefeuille du
contribuable
je souhaiterais que nous puissions
progressivement passer d'un système au
fonds de subvention à la vente de l'ex
trip de l'électricité renouvelable un
système de soutien au développement des
technologies d'énergies renouvelables il
ya une différence vraiment qui me semble
très important
d'un côté on subventionne
artificiellement ont créé un marché
totalement artificielle qui un problème
c'est que ça démantèle complètement la
production d'autres électricité et je
préférais compass
la subvention au développement au
soutien au développement des
technologies qui permettent d'engager
des processus industriels
que ce soit le solaire l'éolien si vous
voulez et qui créent des emplois et qui
est un retour pour le contribuable
français
alors la contribution au service public
de l'électricité grève le coût de
l'électricité
j'ajoute une deuxième chose on fait
porter cette contribution sur l'énergie
la moins polluante
moi je pense qu'il faut faire porter la
contribution aux énergies les plus
carbonée
c'est les énergies les plus carbonées
qui devrait financer le renouvelable
la contribution était plus que doublé
depuis 2002 mais cette extraordinaire de
faire peser ce prix uniquement sur
l'énergie la plus propre en ignorant
totalement les énergies les plus simples
ça pose le problème de l'europe
s'il ya un sujet qui ne va pas c'est
qu'il ya aucune politique énergétique
européenne
donc la première chose que nous
demandons c'est la constitution d'un
marché européen du prix du carbone et
alors là il va falloir que chacun soit
mis devant ses responsabilités
vous savez à quel point je suis attaché
au travail entre l'allemagne et la
france mais ça ne va pas il subventionne
à fond des énergies renouvelables dont
il nous inondent il ouvre à fond des
centrales à charbon qui nous polluent
j'ai beaucoup aimé la remarque de jean
claude qui tout à fait justifié il ya un
moment donné où ça suffit
la france est le bon élève de l'europe
et je demande l'instauration d'une taxe
carbone aux frontières de l'europe pour
que les pays qui produisent en ne
respectant aucune règle de protection de
l'environnement soit taxer aux
frontières de l'europe puisque pour que
en plus du dumping social et fiscal on
n'est pas dans un pays où
l'environnement talent voilà ce que
pourrait être me semble
une partie de l'énergie windows phone un
dernier mot cette fois ci sur la
puissance maritime mondiale
alors nous sommes le deuxième territoire
maritime mondial derrière les etats unis
nous avons en surface maritime 20 fois
le territoire métropolitain de la france
20 fois notre superficie maritime est
supérieure à la chine au canada tout
entier
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait alors nous
allons mettre chez un ami cher daniel la
mer au premier rang de nos
préoccupations
c'est pour cela que nous avons fait un
effort de compétitivité sans précédent
pour les pavillons français on peut pas
continuer comme ça là aussi nous avons
une législation en france de la
dynamique plus contraignante qu'en
europe tous les armateurs se détournent
du pavillon français pourquoi parce que
c'est pas attractif socialement
fiscalement administrativement
deuxièmement il ya un effort ya le
chiffre des échanges maritimes a plus
que triplé
on n'en profite pas donc le pavillon la
baisse des charges pour nos marins et le
problème des ports nous avons en 2007
créer les grands ports maritimes
doté d'une nouvelle gouvernance c'est
pas mal dunkerque à augmenter sa
productivité de 40 % j'étais il ya trois
mois à anvers où le maire d'anvers m'a
dit comme la cgt et sympathique
je les voulais désagréable août et ce
qui se passe mais non il me dit grâce à
la cgt française anvers et rotterdam
sont les grands ports d'europe
voilà la vérité pour le dire
et moi j'ai bien noté c'est pas moi qui
le dit c'est le maire d'anvers
il est temps d'y mettre un terme yannick
fait un travail remarquable en la
matière nous voulons aller beaucoup plus
loin que ce que nous avons fait qu'ils
étaient atteints rappelez-vous déjà les
bagarres sur la réforme des ports en
2007 et cela passe par un basculement
des ports français vers un statut de
droit privé sous la forme de société
anonyme
exactement comme nous l'avions fait à
l'époque pour france télécom de manière
à ce que nos porcs deviennent
compétitifs
le trafic marchandises sur la mer les
autoroutes de la mer se développe de
façon colossale
nous avons une façade maritime immense
pourquoi ne pas en profiter
donc baisse des charges + 2 sur
proposition pour que nos pavillons soit
compétitive et possibilité pour les
ports français de passer sous statut
privé ce qui signifie que la durée de
travail des grutiers et oui il faut que
je rappelle nous on est pour le travail
et est donc notre ambition maritime est
essentielle enfin je termine et en
adressant à nos artisans pêcheurs et
cher daniel un message de confiance
d'abord en disant que les quotas annuels
ça peut plus durer quelle profession
accepterait de devoir gérer ces enjeux
économiques fiscaux et financiers
en attendant des études qui arrivent au
dernier moment
annuellement pas fonctionné comme cela
il est urgent de trouver un équilibre
harmonieux
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
demandons qu'on change
cette évaluation annuelle on associe les
marins pêcheurs aux constats
scientifiques parce que pardon de le
dire mais senti ville de la mer en
savent peut être un peu plus que ce qui
trahit uniquement dans les laboratoires
pour savoir quelle est la ressource
disponible et quel est son évolution me
semble-t-il
il sait mieux que moi yannick dernier
point là dessus je souhaite que on ne
permettent pas l'accompagnement pour
moderniser notre flotte
c'est plus du tout l enjeu il faut
maintenant changer notre flotte la
renouveler et permettent à nos marins
pêcheurs de passer sur les bateaux du
futur ce qui permettra d'éviter toutes
les bagarres qui ont à chaque fois que
le gasoil augmentent eux ne peut plus
s'en sortir
la recette baisse les charges augmentent
comment voulez vous qu'ils s'en sortent
à moins qu'on me dise avec la manche
avec l'atlantique avec la méditerranée
on peut plus de pêcheurs dans ce cas-là
faire mon effort fermons les pêcheurs on
ferme l'agriculture aussi et on regarde
qui merci et enfin pour terminer je vais
également vous dire que nous sommes tout
à fait conscients des problèmes
d'équilibré financier de la france mais
l'équilibré financier de la france ne se
fera pas au détriment des
infrastructures dont la france a besoin
et c'est un message en liaison yannick
et année avec les porcs parce que vous
pouvez même privatiser les ports vous
pouvez changer les ports les rendre
productif et compétitif
si les marchandises déposé cher louis
sur les quais un truc un spécialiste de
la question reste hockey et s'il n'y a
pas d'infrastructure pour les
transporter au coeur de l'europe
ça ne sert à rien c'est la raison pour
laquelle certains gestes nous avions
développé l'idée du canal seine-nord la
question des infrastructures pour
désengorger les ports et faire en sorte
le président 50 aussi pour marseille ça
compte aussi pour tous les ports que
nous connaissons sur la façade
méditerranéenne
c'est un enjeu absolument majeur sur
lequel nous pouvons pas céder
voilà mesdames et messieurs vous l'avez
compris les républicains continuent
cercles le travail de réflexion sur le
projet d'alternance
nous vous donnons rendez vous la semaine
prochaine
pour la convention sur la défense et
nous vous donnons rendez vous le 2
juillet pour un conseil national qui
adoptera la totalité du projet des
républicains je veux que tous les
professionnels qui nous écoutent
sache que si nous rentrons dans le
détail des propositions c'est parce que
nous avons l'intention de tout dire
avant les élections pour être certain de
tout faire après je vous remercie